[Music]
My name is Steven Chin. I run the
developer relations team at Neo Forj.
Um, actually I just started writing a um
a new book on graph rag with O'Reilly.
So that was my weekend was writing
chapters.
um first chapter done. So I think I
think we'll actually put like the
pre-release version of it up soon. Um
and what I am going to talk about for
the next 10 minutes is aentic graph rag
and a little bit about how you can
accomplish this. Okay, so um first of
all, who who here is familiar with graph
databases?
>> Okay, that's really good. Okay, you are
you are well above and ahead of the
curve. Um how many folks have have given
um graph rag a try to to build systems
using graphs?
>> Okay, so one guy in the back, he's the
expert. If you have any questions,
ask him. And just to set the context,
I'm like like why is um we we need we
basically have a problem with a lot of
agentric systems where they're not
meeting use cases as was you know
Gartner's prediction of doom and utter
failure. um and they have a lot of
hallucinations in them. And so um this
is an example. I'm not I'm going to kind
of breeze through this a little bit, but
I basically asked the open3 reasoning
API to solve like a a question about
biases, reasoning, and math. And the the
basic problem is it it doesn't do a good
job if you don't give it enough deep
information sources of answering things
correctly. And um the question is like
how many girls you can fit in a
classroom? So like it's a tech computer
science bias. It's a little bit about
like math and reasoning because I ask it
about a grid. It it it inaccurately
anchors. Um these are the grid sizes
which you could choose on the number of
girls you can fit. It inaccurately
anchors on some article about a um um
non-attacking kings problem. Assumes the
squares it's a square like grid. So like
the audience, you guys always win
against the reasoning AI even though it
takes 40 seconds to to noodle on this
and it it further. So I ask like um are
the are the girls and boys going to go
to home economics or to um um
whatchamacallit to to sports and again
it this is both a bias and also I misled
it by giving information about the ratio
of girls and boys and it comes up with
an answer calculating that all the girls
will go to cooking class which is which
is horrible. I mean I I'm the chef at
home and I I love cooking. Um so I think
that these these are the biases. Now,
this is kind of funny because we can
reason about the situation and it's like
as a problem that we can think about,
but imagine if this was like in life
sciences about drug discovery or if
you're if you're solving a supply chain
issue. So, the fact the LM has has gone
and inserted biases, it's done incorrect
reasoning along the way. This means
you're going to get the wrong business
results and it's very hard to figure
this out. So basically the problem is
the the LM is good at extrapolating
information like like doing language
tasks, figuring out things and it it
gives the impression of intelligence
where there's there's no real
intelligence. There's no real kind of
human reasoning behind it. And so we we
overcribe things it can do and there's a
bunch of things it can't do well. Now
those those are things that knowledge
graphs are actually really good at. So
one way we can solve this problem is by
throwing more computers at it, more
agents, right? And um agentic systems
are good at improving the quality of
results because you have LLMs talking to
each other and reasoning with each other
about the problem. So like you know
basically agents who observe, they think
and they take actions. So you have
different types of agents which are
doing different things in the workflow.
Um an agentic runtime might look
something like this where you you're
building out and you have a um
orchestration layer which is is working
on the agents. You have some geni models
hooked up. You have some tools
um and then these all collaborate to
give you better results than one LM to
give you can give you together. Now the
challenge with this is that it's a very
monolithic architecture. It's hard to
maintain. It's hard to swap out the
tools and it also kind of puts you in a
situation where you can't secure the
system. You can't do a bunch of things.
So a good way to solve this is using
MCP.
You kind of use MCP as your tools where
your agents are talking to them. Um with
MCP now you have your servers and you
have your data sources which are now
talking to each other. Um you have your
client and server. So now you can give
it um you know files or database
records. you can give it a graph
database as the system of record and we
built a bunch of tools at Neo Forj on
top of MCP. So we built um a cipher tool
which cipher is the query language for
graph databases. Um so what basically
it'll it'll use it'll when you ask the
MCP server it gives capabilities to
generate cipher queries off of prompts
or questions or the things you want to
pass it. We have a memory module. So
this gives you some agent memory you can
use to plug into agentic systems and
then we also have um MCP on top of our
cloud APIs if you want to provision
databases or do different things on top
of it. And I think this is a pattern
you'll see with a lot of people who are
the vendors or building things is now
you can plug these tools into your agent
architecture and you can use them
together with your your graph. Typically
like agents are represented in some sort
of graph. This is a picture of a lang
graph agent
and you can layer memory on top of it.
So these are all folks who just spoke in
our panel. So Zep, Cognney, Memz, we're
all talking about their approach to
agents. Um actually they all run on top
of Neo Forj. Um so they use Neo Forj as
the core graph database as and some of
them are pluggable. So you can choose
your graph database of choice, but
they're a really good way of giving
memory to your agents, which is
graph-based and matches the way LM want
to store, communicate, and retrieve
information. And um also um one of our
other speakers on the graph track showed
his architecture for doing video search
and summarization. And if you notice um
they they do a bunch of this already,
right? So they they do short-term
memory, they have um a whole bunch of
lookup information, and they give you a
choice of they they have both a graph
rag pipeline and a vector pipeline. So I
I highlighted the graph rag in in red.
And the reason they're doing this is
because when you use graph rag, you get
some advantages in terms of the results
coming back and typically a lower rate
of hallucinations. This would be are
like direct LMS are kind of you know
they give you very generic responses to
a healthcare question. Um baseline rag
you get better results back but it's
it's incomplete because it's doing um
basically it's doing vector similarity.
So similarity is not relevance. It it
doesn't mean it actually understands the
problem. Um this would be a system which
does graph rag and the the typical
pattern that would get you this is um
first do your search in a in a vector
search. You could use a vector database.
We also support vector search on top of
neoraj and it gives you back results and
that's a good way of translating the
question into like vectors and then you
have mappings from the vector embeddings
to your graph and you you pull back the
nodes which are relevant. So in this
case like you're asking about a um
emphyma you'd get back the the node for
emphyma you'd pull back all the related
nodes and diagnosis and conditions and
you see it's just it lists them all
right so it's a very effective way to
get really good responses back when
you're dealing with something where you
you kind of have this mix of structured
and unstructured data. Here's a quick
architecture of how you could put this
together using you know you're using
traversal and vector similarity. um you
take in the question, you do the query
against either vectors or knowledge
graphs. Um graph data science or graph
analytics are helpful as well to do
community algorithms and groupings and
things like this. Um some of this is in
the Microsoft graph rag paper and other
research which is going on in this area
and um you feed that back as context to
the LM to improve the quality of the
answers. Um some of the patterns I've
talked about quickly. So text to cipher
is what our MCP server does. It's it can
be good but sometimes it can be really
bad because the generation of cipher by
LLMs is not as good as you need it for
some cases. Um the one I was talking
about is as um which one was it? Um
basically vector search with graph
context, right? So you do a vector
search and then you use that to pull
back related nodes in graph context.
That's a really good pattern to start
with. And um you can also do pre and
post filtering of vector results to
bubble things which are more relevant to
the top of the context. Um certain
systems this is quite good as well
because all you want to do is make sure
the LM gets things higher up in the
buffer for context windows. Even if LMS
now have larger context windows
basically what what the eval show is
they ignore most of it and they look at
the stuff at the top. Okay. So a quick
example of a company which is doing
this. So CLA basically replaced all of
their SAS systems with the great graph
rag project. Um they're one of our
customers. Um they took an enterprise
wiki's HR systems internal
documentation.
250k employee questions after the first
year. 2,000 daily queries process and
85% employee adoption. So like a really
good adoption of this technology.
Um and I'll give you a couple resources
and I think we're at time. Is that about
right crew? you have five minutes.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Oh, I see there's five minutes between
sessions. I was I was rushing to do this
even quicker. Okay, so we have time for
questions, which is great. Um, so one
resource I'd recommend is the um Neo
Forj certified developer program. Um, so
with the number of hands in the room
here for folks who said they know
graphs, I'm pretty sure you could all
pass the Neo Forj certified exam if you
just took it today. and we basically
will will mail you a Neo forj certified
t-shirt. You get a little LinkedIn badge
to put on your profile and it's a nice
way to just show the world that like you
actually know this stuff like you know
graph technology you know stuff. We'll
probably add in additional
certifications for like you know graph
rag and other stuff in the future but
the base certified developer class is a
good way just to get base knowledge in
this and we do have classes in graph
academy on building chat bots using LMS
using all this stuff as well. Um second
resource is our nodes conference. So the
Neo Forj nodes conference is an annual
conference. It runs in three different
time zones 24 hours all free content,
free sessions, you know, come come out
and join and check out some of this
content.
Okay, I'll let people finish who want to
do the QR code. And thank you very much
for coming. And we have a few minutes
for questions. Okay, so what we'll do is
anyone who has questions, just raise
your hand, shout it out. If anyone wants
to leave the room, feel free to do that
as well. I don't want to keep you
trapped in here. Okay. So, in the back
>> to be clear,
you embed that do a semantic search
and grab
is that the correct basic
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, the question is
like what the pattern is for for doing
this type of search and that that's
exactly right. So, so basically what
you're doing is you're you're using the
LM for what it's good at, which is
language translation. So the user can
enter whatever convoluted question they
want, which would never translate to a
beautiful cipher query. And then you you
first tell the LM, well, do a vector
search on that, like find vector
similarity in this. And then because
you've generated like the graph and the
embeddings to point to each other now
you can go to the graph and you can say
well this these these embeddings all
point to this node in the graph. So it's
probably about in the in the case
emphyma. Now I want to pull back the
nodes which are either like you could
use cosine similarity or you could use
um um community grouping algorithms or
different algorithms to figure out
what's relevant and then pass that as
context.
>> So in a simple architecture the
What
>> the chunks you embed and your nodes are
the same.
>> Yeah. So, so like what we typically do
and this is what'll happen if you um
import unstructured data into Neo forj.
Well, we we we can create a node
structure out of it using LMS and then
you hang your embeddings your text
embeddings off as properties off of the
nodes.
>> Who does that? Who does that?
>> Um so we have a couple plugins for this.
We have a Neo Forj Python library which
that has will do a lot of this. Uh we
also have an integration with Langchain.
>> So you can use lang chain or um llama
index
>> or haststack.
>> You can pick your own whatever.
>> Yeah. So whatever framework you want to
do, you can choose and we pretty much
have integrations with all of them to to
help with the um
>> associations.
>> Yeah, the associations.
>> Okay. And there were a bunch of hands,
but I don't know who's first, so
>> you you can go.
that you have server memory. Does it
handle the logic
and so on or exposes all the
other framework?
>> Okay. So, so the question is about like
how the MCP agent for memory works. Um,
so that that is a great question, but
>> I actually don't know the answer. It's a
it's an open source MTP server. Now,
Now if if you want the answer
um the session which I'm giving with
Michael Hunger and Jesus um in I don't
know in a bit um Michael's team built
all the MCP servers so he he actually
will know the answer and yeah it's it's
today I think it's right after this or
shortly after this and Michael will go
on for hours if you ask him that. So
that's a a great question. Okay and
we're at time you get the last question.
>> Yeah. So I want to ask about your
opinion between lang chain and lang
graph frameworks. Are they like
complimentary or they're like
>> what's your perspective on that?
>> Um okay so the question is like like
lang chain versus lang graph. I thought
I thought lang graph was like the agent
thing that the lang chain folks built.
No
>> did did you did you use any of that?
Like I'm also new to that.
Yeah. So we we have a bunch of
experiments and prototypes with um
Langraph for for doing agents and
things. Um we have integrations with
Langchain.
>> We also integrate with all the other
memory vendors. I mean like I I would
say from our perspective, use the tool
that's best for you and we'll integrate
with everything.
>> Yeah. Okay. Thanks for coming.
[Music]